[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings despite
unrelenting defense by ukrainian forces
russia has taken a key city in the
country's south according to a local
official here you can see russian
military trucks and tanks rolling
through the streets of kirsan the city
of nearly 300 000 along the black sea
would be the largest ukrainian city to
fall since the invasion began a week ago
the people of ukraine are not backing
down this video shows hundreds forming a
human wall to stop russian troops from
taking over a nuclear facility
and here unarmed protesters marched with
ukrainian flags even after hearing
russian gunfire think about that for a
second
senator lindsey graham says russian
president vladimir putin should be
investigated for war crimes and he is
urging the senate to pass a resolution
supporting an international criminal
court investigation into putin and his
regime's quote war crimes against
humanity and war crimes against the
people of ukraine and others close quote
and senator graham joins us now senator
graham thank you very much for being
here you've been
one of the most persistent and public
critics of vladimir putin in congress
i'm thinking about you inviting a
dissident not that long ago to actually
testify against him in the united states
congress uh on the war crimes question
what was the breaking point for you
before this extraordinary press
conference yesterday
when they started using uh band
munitions like cluster bombs uh vacuum
bombs everything he's doing is illegal
under the law of war and the
international criminal court during the
balkans conflict really came about
in the 90s and we had 161 people from
privates to prime ministers prosecuted
for war crimes there is no rule of law
in russia to hold putin accountable so
this international tribunal is the right
way to go i talked to the british
yesterday and we're going to come up
with a plan to start
identifying russian units and give the
world the names of the commanders of the
people who are doing this so i want a
multiple front approach when it comes to
putin
and those who are carrying out this war
economic sanctions aid to the ukrainians
so they can fight back but i want every
military commander and every pilot to
know in russia that if you carry out
these atrocities against the ukrainian
people you do so at your own peril
you're going to wind up in the dark
so let's linger on those atrocities for
a second senator because it doesn't take
an expert in military tactics to look at
the putin situation and say he's in
trouble the ukrainian people are putting
up a tremendous fight he's got no way
out it seems except through so this
could get very bad yeah thinking back to
world war ii is there a moment for
americans for the american military
where we say as human beings as people
we can't let this stand anymore we need
to do something in the country
well you know that's a really good
question i'm not supporting ground
american ground forces in ukraine like
everybody else i move to tears by the
ukrainians will to fight the cities will
begin to fall but the insurgency will
linger and this war could go on for a
very long time i'm trying to make it
real to the people carrying out the war
that if you follow putin you could wind
up losing your own freedom so what i
hope will happen here is that the world
not just the american people
will will make a case against putin
that's been unmade for 20 years he has
literally jailed opponents in russia
poisoned people he carpet bombed aleppo
in syria and idlib syria and chechnya
and nothing happened enough is enough
china is watching i want the chinese to
know that if you go down this road with
taiwan you may wind up not only being
sanctioned but going to jail one day
it is shocking senator to watch this in
real time right before our eyes
like you everybody has moved to tears by
what we're seeing in ukraine but you've
said this if putin gets away with this
the u.s will pay a very heavy price so
how far should the us be willing to go
to defend what is happening here yeah i
heard you say no boots on the ground but
how far should we go right
okay the achilles heel of the
putin war machine is oil and gas sector
the byte administration is coming around
to the idea of sanctioning russian oil
and gas it's about 40 of the income of
russia comes from russian oil and gas
four percent of our energy oil comes
from russia we can make that up if we
choose to but every barrel of oil coming
out of russia has blood in it so if you
hit the oil and gas sector that will
further crush the rupal but this front
about legal liability
trust me the people carrying out this
war
need to understand that they're exposed
as individuals so the one thing we could
do that we're not doing is going after
the oil and gas sector and the other
thing is elevate the determination of
the world to hold these people
accountable for committing war crimes
so senator when it comes to the oil and
gas question uh and it's a good one
it presumes that president putin
continues to be a rational actor that he
is not a crazy person that he will back
down if he is threatened financially or
his economy is threatened you've been
watching him for a long time do you
still believe and not everyone does that
he is a rational player in on the world
stage
i think he's got a plan to destroy
ukraine and to bring
certain satellite soviet states back
into his orbit uh in terms of a nuclear
exchange the french had the best answer
we have weapons too and you know nobody
wins a nuclear war so i'm not dr phil i
can't tell you what makes this guy tick
but i can't tell you we can crush the
ruble we can destroy the russian economy
the russian people are not our enemy uh
it is putin we're fighting a man in a in
a small group of people the oligarchs
are beginning to lose their yachts i
want the military commanders to know you
know is this who you want your country
to be are you going to follow this guy
to the gates of hell
there's a chance to break putin from his
people and everything we can do to hurt
the russian economy i hate it for the
russian people makes this more
unsustainable so we got a moment in
history to do something with putin we
haven't done it 20 years put him out of
the game
senator i want to ask you to be dr phil
but i will ask you to predict something
for me you have warned that if ukraine
is successful in standing their ground
that putin will your words go scorched
earth what does that look like do you
believe that he will go beyond ukraine
uh i don't know if you'll go beyond
ukraine but here's what's going to
happen urban warfare is very difficult
we learned that in iraq and afghanistan
so if a sniper shoots a russian soldier
from an apartment building what we would
do is try to isolate the sniper what
they will do is destroy the
apartment building he's going scorched
earth here he's going to start
disassembling all resistance he has no
look at aleppo if you want to know the
playbook for putin checks nia he
leveled the place olympia aleppo
syria barrel bombs coming out of
helicopters that's the russian game plan
and they're all war crimes and the world
complained but we moved on we can't move
on when it comes to ukraine china's
watching iran is watching
yeah senator graham you've had your eyes
focused on putin now for many years we
appreciate you coming on to share your
perspective as this tragedy continues to
unfold please come back to us